Hi, I'm Anna Akana, and you're receiving this video because you sent my friend your unsolicited unasked-for
dick. *scary noises*
Now I'm willing to forgive an honest mistake, maybe you forgot to ask
"Hey, would you actually just see my dick?" and you just got so excited you just sent the dick anyway.
That's okay! We can forgive that once.
But if you do it again,
here's what I'm gonna do to your dick
This is your dick!
[Voiceover] Cut that dick!
[Voiceover] Stop all over that dick
This is your dick!
[Voiceover] Do it!
*whispers* I curse your dick
[Voiceover] curse that dick
This is your dick!
[Voiceover] Yeah, throw that dick!
Wow that's...far
*monsters cheering* You want this you filthy animals?! *ominous laughter*  Rip it apart!
I'll stab that dick. Stab stab!
[Voiceover] Stab stab stab!
I'll break that diiiick
[Voiceover] Break that dick *pencil snaps* yaass
I broke it
[Voiceover] Throw a funeral for that dick
*ominous laughter*